no I didn't something about yourself
thank you Pastor
shut up I got it I can do German boy I
can no I'm tired I didn't fart can I
tell that story we shouldn't tell any
more stories my battles answer no no no
no I'm just like no why not it's really
funny okay all right okay hello
everybody hello everybody my name is
markiplier this weight is last video
recording night hey we're trying to get
June as best we can okay so with the
reason we're so giggly right now it's
cuz we remembered something to happen
okay basically wait farted it we've
heard it here while we're sitting at the
lights and it was so bad that I had to
run out of the room and then he came
after me but he closed the door behind
him I notice so we're out there for like
five minutes
talking and it's like getting really
like okay let's do this we gotta go
we're gonna record and like the second I
open the door it was like the cloud of
fire was just like hide mine the door
waiting for me and like ran up my
Huddle's I can immediately write my
music oh wow ah run back again stop
laughing he's laughing so hard
he'd go pee idiot he kept laughing so
hard as steel bouncing somewhat I wasn't
watching
we should ha that's what you said that's
what you said and the monks okay explain
honey how are you explaining know hello
everybody who uh comin home
I'm getting to do dentures again I get
to do it okay I'll tell it after we face
let's go don't make me go down this time
yeah okay what is happening right there
shut up I don't know why are you winning
why aren't I winning oh no no hey hey ho
hey ho what's gonna do yes yes yes yes
yes
today does it make it it bleep buddy
bloopin sense what do you mean bleep
buddy blue buddy said I be every game we
play is be the opposite of normal don't
understand it either okay so the other I
think like I inhaled your heart
anyway bring up a boy there's another
part of the port story there's another
part to it so this is so weird because
like you're watching this right in like
for the future but we just recorded all
these now so we were out there again cuz
we need a breather cuz we were laughing
so hard in our heads hurt from just
screaming so much so we're out there I
was riding the scooter around and wait
was walk Wade was drinking water over by
the counter far away and he farts again
he like Haley like it's so loud I can
hear the other side he burns again and
he he couldn't stand the smell of it
well yeah hold on said way that's true
burger yeah that's absolutely he
couldn't stand the smell of it so I'm
like I have my scooter and he runs
around in a circle to get away from it
I'm like I'm going in I take the scooter
I'm like whee and I'm taking the big
loss of brettly you've done this kind of
friendship we have okay I think I'm done
I think I'm gonna clear so up literally
I don't smell anything
it's weird so I turned my head go huh
I don't Oh
last minute I get rather guys is all the
sudden it was waiting like around the
desk Ian like look at that market boy oh
yeah them again really jump in front of
me and got me and again cowlick dying
over fight I go again again just to see
who they're all right okay
oh ah that's one out of two or something
no no oh the neck ones for all the beam
okay there's two gonna be new I don't
know okay let's next one's for all the
beans okay all right no no oh no why is
this happening Oh No haha that's my only
points no oh I bet negative turn haha
dagger die oh ah no oh no no no no you
were doing you like like trying to
predict him about a half I know I used
to be good at that I don't know what
happened in between you damn it ah oh I
thought I was gonna piss boom oh I got a
point
waiter boom boom oh yeah damn it damn it
damn damn damn damn it
nothing's ever gonna have a damn oh my
god you actually come back no oh
break your combo there wait awarenss
yeah all right now it actually is best
to a three this is the tiebreaker this
is a tiebreaker this literally is for
all the beam because it's the tie
frickin way whoa jeez man I was just
like trying like here we go there we go
here we go we gotta go okay man whatever
you see me in boom oh damn it not for
you not for you oh nothing there
haha oh yeah oh yeah that was a waiter
yeah I had the helmet what is happening
no no no perfect no this is such baloney
this is baloney no ma no yeah you know
what that was you
Oh God I knew you missed it buddy
mmm
oh yeah yes one who won who won who won
who won who won red one red one the red
one to practice red one third round baby
for all the bend
we did it coming at you from markimoo
central we warned maybe I don't know
when that light left I think it's
because I know it has not been gone a
third game oh but hey for a long
horrible Marga new spin area from our
EMU central I'm the winner baby there's
no birth winner shop I am the winner
photo show I am when Photoshop well the
game was still recording what are you
dying
it was photo Sean I'm the winner hey
guys
you wouldn't I believe what happened
yeah okay so right as I was about to win
I came back in one Wade was shaking the
table in rage as losing so badly that
the webcam power cord that has been
pulled out before that happened the same
time the same thing happened just
God sorry sorry the same thing happened
as I was playing five nights at Freddy's
3 for a nightmare uh mode on like the
was it the time you want it was a time
I'm loving right after I won I pushed
the camera off of the desk and it just
fell over and I didn't even know that
I'm like I want I'm so bad I want ball
hammers which I can readily admit I just
did a cool a clean sweep of the entire
four series so I mean that's good for me
wait what okay so thank you everybody so
much for watching though Thank You
someone who you're with oh I really
appreciate outwait Channel yes he loses
a lot over there but I mean hey that's
who he is that's kind of his personality
so no but seriously thank you guys so
much sincerely for watching these these
are the most fun things that I do and I
enjoy them to death and I can't wait to
just watch these and post and edit these
so that I can put them up on the channel
but sincerely thank you guys so much for
watching thank you for giving me a
chance to play with my good buddy here
and just enjoy life and do what I do so
thank you wait for being here my
pleasure thank you guys for watching and
as always we will see you in the next
video
oh wow wowie